great to see you looking sassier lf-cc
how you enjoyed it today oh my god it's
so busy it's the cutest not stop we've
been here since like nine o'clock and
it's just been relentlessly busy so it's
it's kind of yeah it's great it's crazy
last time we saw you it's been so
dramatic Game of Thrones
how can you get more dramatic but mega
dramatic season 3 what was your reaction
to the word war add a red wedding was
Oona and Michelle and and and Richard
absolutely smashed it that's everyone
did the Uni was sucked it was amazing
he's powerful powerful stuff I remember
watching him my flatmate and I knew what
was going to happen and I was just kind
of like sitting there behind him just
watching his reaction it was yeah it was
brilliant really really good go red
wedding reaction babe actually it was
more like oh yeah yeah oh yeah obviously
it was incredible there wasn't amazing
but I want to know as well because you
know we've seen some scenes of you and
Cersei this season what are you thinking
about the prospect of marrying her
personally I think Lena's great so yes
as Loras [ __ ] no way I think it's I
think it's a real shame for Loras like
to be in that position
especially after Renly but I've not seen
the script yet for season four so it'll
be interesting to see how it pans out
yeah if you could choose your own
partner or if you were gonna be king of
Westeros we could have your own queen of
Westeros who would it be if I could have
my own king or queen and Westeros who
would it be
I think I'd go with the the hot tree you
know you know the tree though the the
I'd go with the tree Loras and the tree
for life if you had to give Loras some
advice for the seasons coming what would
it be I'm thinking maybe like stay away
from Cersei be strong don't let your
family [ __ ] you around anymore stand up
for yourself keep your hair looking good
keep the sass and just be stronger and
what do you think about Cersei threats
well barely veiled threats tomorrow as
well your sister hey I'm Loras Tyrell
you know I can take any one of those
novices another Jamie's got his hand
caught he stands no chance so they can
bring it but I'm gonna I'm gonna dish it
back hardcore so take it Lana so Jaime
Lannister down downtown downtown
underground he he is finished dad he
won't know where are you he won't even
know where he is he's just off off the
plateau of birth he's like he's he's
down like where there's no even space
anymore he's just like he's going down
ask you about the qualities that you
think you need to stay alive any baby
even thriving great with friends and you
think Loras has got them I think Loras
has got them yet you've got to have a
position of power Loras is the heir of
Highgarden news to me so he's got he's
got he's in a position of power of
influence so and there's there's a price
on his head I think you've got to be
quick witted you've got to be strong you
gotta have good chat and you've got to
have good people around you I think
you're gonna be having good support
around you and even though you know his
family kind of do you know hug him off a
bit by you know marrying him off to one
person another person and you know
they've they've kind of got their
family's best interests at heart so he's
got support as well we've seen so many
people fall by the wayside haven't we
ended up on the pile of bodies on Game
of Thrones this season adding the
Parsons as well now obviously we're not
wanting to lose you anytime soon but if
you had to go out how would you like
your death to take place something
outrageous like flamboyant like real
Lauren well I like the idea of getting
burnt by what by oil but like really
like like like I'm kind of like Madonna
s kind of like stage show debt yeah yeah
very whimsical like I'm out already
who do you think's had a really really
good death so far of all of them who
wins best death on the show who wins
best debt to be honest I love Oona's
death that just being stabbed in the
belly was just so pallette at the table
just from behind and just got that but
just the anguish of like you can almost
see like it wasn't even like she was
caring about herself dying she thought
about her baby dying first and it was
just wow so powerful yeah yeah stabbed
in the belly
good Game of Thrones is nuts
now what have been your own oh my god
what the back moments on the show so far
but to be honest I've not got Sky
Atlantic so I've not actually seen most
of it I've just kind of googled my bits
and my friends bits and like the big
bits and and seen that I have yet to see
the whole thing together so I'm planning
on maybe when the box it comes out or
when I get sky or whatever I'm gonna sit
down and watch it all together but I
just not had the time or it's not been
around but
and I think it's good to watch it all in
one go because they it's so much tension
every week I know I know I just see
little clips here in there and it's you
know bad fin
you know I should watch the whole thing
but it's kind of its kind of weird to
watch it back because you know everyone
so well when you know the sets and it's
a different experience watching it as an
act of being in it as to watching it as
like a just a you know a regular
audience member talked about people
who've fallen by the wayside have a
great sexy to go but if you could bring
anyone back if you could bring someone
back to live who would it be
I mean it's obviously I'm gonna have to
obviously say Renly on I that's such a
cliche thing to say but actually I think
I'd like to bring back I'd like to bring
back Michelle Catelyn wonderful well she
does such an amazing performance and I'd
love to see more of her in the show it's
a real shame that she's left but you
know obviously obviously redly who bring
boat really Norris is so over that guy I
mean how did you see Oliver did you see
that guy's butt height right
like yeah Renly Britney whoo yeah Randy
who couldn't bring what shooter here
give me that bum no will was great
actually it was really great working
with will bless him it was like the
first thing he's he'd like kind of done
big-time and immediately like he was
asked to get naked and yeah he was a
real pro and he just you know he got
naked with confidence and styles so what
do you like to see happen in season four
for Lawrence I know you said he haven't
my description I'd like to see him have
I kind of some kind of like tension with
Jaime I think that'd be really
interesting especially over the Cersei
thing there's a lot of stuff to be done
like maybe a scene with Brienne but you
know that there's so many characters to
fit in and the show is just becoming so
all-encompassing
I think I find I just kind of go with
the flow really but I'd like to see
Norris get burnt with oil like sassy way
and maybe have some tension with Jaime
yeah I think Jamie's gonna like him with
being with her fears no I don't think
both of them both are not keen on the
prospect both them hate the idea and I
think that mutual hate of the plan might
actually bring them together in it in a
very strange way and also be interesting
to see now that Jaime's lost his hand
Loras has actually got the upper hand
you know he you know he has the power so
I think there's there's some
possibilities for some very interesting
dynamics between the two characters I
think you for you and also for one of
your favorite shows Adventure Time now
people are saying a live-action movie
with Finn playing Finn what would you
say to that
I'd be speechless I think I'd actually
pass out that would be like my dream
role but I think I'm too old to play
real time in the demon I can just play
it in my bedroom leave my bed with like
my my my cat is
as Jake I love it so much I've not seen
them like the last couple of episodes
but yeah we'd like to see human oh yeah
yeah the petition no petition now right
now yeah finally
what's it meant to you to be part of
Game of Thrones and what would you like
to say to the fans out there watching
this video
[ __ ] hell Game of Thrones has changed
my life it's it's it's you know mate
it's just incredible it's amazing to be
a part of a show that's so well put
together it's wonderful to have people
come up to you that not only Jesus like
God's Game of Thrones you're that guy
from Game of Thrones they respect the
work and it's it's it's really special
as an actor to be part of something
that's global well respected and well
loved and I guess occur to the fans to
the audience that watch it just like a
massive thank you and at you know a
mutual appreciation of the love that is
put out there it's it's um it's just so
wonderful to to be a part of something
where there is so much love involved you
know it's a really good thing there's
there's so much [ __ ] in the world right
now and I think just to be a part of
something where where everyone can just
be like into it and on a level with it
and talk about it yes it's a lot of
pride in love
you